this talk is going to be about data
processing that Apache beam it will be
in the similar vein if you were in this
session earlier where we talked about
how to use scalar signs added Python
with Apache spark and beam is a
different take on trying to solve a
similar problem where how do you use
Python for planning data processing
pipeline using different execution
frameworks let me introduce myself I'm
sorry I worked as a software engineer
and I spend a lot of time on Twitter for
some reason and so now that you guys
know more about me let's talk about what
is being so what is the patchy beam
Apache beam is a unified data processing
framework for expressing efficient and
portable data processing pipelines so
here this is a long lengthy definition I
want to talk about two keywords here
unified and portable by unified what I
mean here is the beam model should be
able to express a lot of different use
cases that we see in the common data
processing paradigm so these can be
batch pipelines that might run daily
monthly things like that or streaming
pipelines that are continuously running
from a source such as Kafka and you're
doing stream processing on those and
then the next thing I want to highlight
is portable so in the beam model your
pipeline should be able to run on any of
the execution frameworks that you choose
so the user from beams perspective
writes a graph and expresses their
pipeline and beam and that pipeline
should be able to run on any execution
framework such as apache spark apache
flink or Google Cloud dataflow so
currently beam supports different
runners and we can and they all provide
an consistent API for running and
defining your pipeline so as we dive
more into these two paradigms first
let's talk about what kind of data do we
see in today's use cases and how do
different data processing jobs make
trade-offs around what is the right
framework for them so let's say you were
a mobile game
company and you launched your new
favorite famous game called geometry
crush where people who are asked to
click on different geometrical shapes
and they earn points using that and this
game becomes really popular all across
the globe people are submitting they are
playing your game on any plane any train
any bus that you ride and you're
constantly collecting scores your data
grows and in your warehouse you come up
with the intelligent strategy of
sharding your data by day and all your
analytics is done on this but in all
honesty what your data actually looks
like is a continuous stream coming in
and if somebody is playing your game at
8 o'clock in the morning you see that
data come in immediately and this person
might have very good Network and you see
that score if somebody was in a train
and they were in a tunnel for a while
you might see their score like 10
minutes late and if they were on an
aircraft playing your game you might
even see the score like 6 hours later so
this this data is unbounded as you are
constantly getting in streams and it's
delayed and delayed by an not well
defined paradigm so in most leaming
pipelines what you do in these cases is
you bucket your data in certain fashion
where you can say I'm going to calculate
wind date values per R by bucketing my
data from 12:00 to 1:00 1:00 to do but
all this is based on what time did you
receive the data and not on what time
did your event happen so a DM we try to
cross differentiate between these two
concepts of when the event actually
happened and when you are actually
processing this data so in most data
processing jobs here you are kind of
making a trade-off between three
different choices where what K what kind
of completeness do you see so how
correct or godaddy a result so because
of late data you can't actually out
correctly say hey I've seen everything
from for the window of 12 o'clock to 1
o'clock at 3:00 in the afternoon that's
definitely not true because somebody
might be on a plane or latency so if you
decided to wait too long and say I'm
going to wait 24 hours
for my data to show up so that I can
guarantee that I've seen everything
you're still only getting results are
once every 24 hours instead of getting
results continuously and then there's
cost where people don't want to spend
too much and running these jobs so
minimizing cost for every one of these
jobs is definitely important so to drive
this point home I want to talk about how
different use cases make trade-offs
between these three dimensions so here
on the y-axis have plotted importance so
we hire the bar be more important we
think this per this dimension is for
this job and on the x-axis we have the
three dimensions of completeness latency
and cost so let's say you were a SAS
company which runs a monthly pipeline so
every time a user makes an API call to
your service you build them a certain
amount and at the end of the month you
just count number of API calls received
per account and builder so here
completeness is very very important your
business is based on a trust that you're
like counting these API calls correctly
you are not overcharging your users so
here we want to guarantee that the
results are as correct as possible while
latency is not that important this
pipeline runs once a month so if it
takes two hours versus three hours
that's not the end of the world and
you're only going to get results once a
month it's not a continuous learning
sign and low cost is not that important
because this is a monthly job so if it
costs you a certain extra one for
getting hundred percent correct result
it should be okay but for the same case
let's say you wanted to give a running
estimate of the bill to the user so that
they're not surprised at the end of the
month by getting a huge bill or if one
of their services goes wild and starts
making a whole bunch of API calls to
your system you should they should see
an uptick in their estimate and not only
get the results at the end of the month
so here we can compromise just a bit on
the completeness your estimate can't be
too off but they don't need to be 100%
correct constantly but we want to get
the results much more faster so instead
of getting them once
once per month you want to see something
update at least maybe 10 minutes or so
and because this is an estimate pipeline
this is not delay like but you can you
want to save on cost because you're
slightly compromising on result
correctness of the result so you want to
save a bit on the cost and moving this
like to a different domain and let's say
we had a fraud detection pipeline here
completeness becomes much more much less
important because you're mostly trying
to minimize false negatives where any
fraud that might have leaked through
your system your objective is to catch
that and latency is very very important
here because you want to catch any fraud
that happens as soon as it happens
so if you see a credit card making
transactions where it shouldn't you want
to block that card immediately and
presumably low cost is slightly less
important than our billing estimate
pipeline because a cost of a fraud is
much much higher than running the
pipeline so that shouldn't be a problem
so now that we have seen these use cases
and how different pipelines interact
between exactness and latency let's talk
about how the beam model tries to build
a paradigm where it lets the user decide
what kind of choices it wants to make so
before we dive into the beam model I
want to clarify certain terms that you
might hear me talk about so what is a
pipeline pipeline is an execution
bag where this is the steps that the
user asked the input data to go through
so these can be like hey there are two
different input streams I want to go if
I want to both ask them to go through
each of these transformations or make
them join somewhere then output to a
sink which might be a database or text
file somewhere and then a single
transformation is called a P transform
where this is the parallelizable
transform so this transform is can be
applied to different parts of the stream
in different workers and similarly the
data that goes between a single
transform to another transform or from a
transform to a sink from a source to a
transform is a P connection so
P collection is kind of like a set of
elements which might be infinite in size
and you might not be able to observe all
of it if it's a streaming source such as
Kafka so that's what bounded and
unbounded P collections mean we're a
bounded P collection is something where
your data is static where if you are
doing data processing on a fixed set of
files you already know when this data
ends while if you were reading from
let's say Twitter for a Twitter stream
you don't know when it's going to end
because you might constantly be getting
new adding new to it so now that we have
clarified those terminologies I really
touched upon event time and processing
time so event time is the time when the
event actually happened so if somebody
is playing the mobile game at 8 o'clock
the event time is 8 and processing time
is at what per time are you processing
this data so in case of a streaming
pipeline your event time versus plus
sitting time processing time are very
close to each other you try to process
the data as soon as that happens or your
system sees it while if you were running
a batch pipeline you might be processing
data which is a year old so your event
time is a year ago and your processing
time is what when your pipeline is
running so to explain the beam model we
try to phrase the conversation around
asking four different questions where
what is being computed where in event
time is it being computed when in
processing time is it being computed and
how do you refine any results that you
might see because of a data so first
what is being computed here so this code
snippet what we try to do is we have an
input pipeline and we want to pipe this
output input through a P transform
called some odd integer per key where
this is similar to let's say you had a
reducer which was doing some overall the
integers that were attached to
particular key so example would be if
you were calculating cumulative scores
for each user in the last day or last 24
hours something like that and here we
haven't added any notion of
what time do we wanna calculate this so
far so this is very similar to what the
typical batch pipeline would look like
where you have data and you assume that
you have seen everything in the future
or in the past so all you're doing is
calculating a rolling sum so in the
batch case you're not waiting for future
data or something like that and you
would get one output for one key so for
one user you're going to get one value
of treta and but let's say we wanted for
this we had to know that all the event
time data has been collected so the next
thing is we want to say we want to
window our event time and generate an
output per window so so in this snippet
what we do is if you look at the flu
line they're saying window my input
stream into fixed windows of two minute
size each so what you're going to see is
in your input stream there will be
buckets of two minute windows each and
you're going to get a sum which is for
that window so now the number of output
you are going to see is basically one
sum for each user each window so that
would look something like this where for
every two-minute window you are getting
an output value but as you note here
that still we are assuming that for a
particular window we have seen all the
data for that window so for a window
from 12 o'clock to 1202 we have seen all
that data and that is the sum we're
calculating so this is kind of like
windowed batch where we were calculating
let's say you had a KPI around number of
active users per day and we want to say
hey split my stream based on per day
like per day and then calculate number
of active users in black window and this
is what a windowed batch pipeline
generally looks like and now let's say
we added a notion of so before we talk
about processing time beam allows you to
specify three different sorts of windows
where in the previous example we saw a
fixed windows we
like hey calculating me a thumper ah
give me a sum per day something like
that but you could also have rolling
windows where you're constantly doing
the rolling some where number of active
users per last 24 days or last 28 days
which is a typical metric or you could
have session windows where let's say you
wanted to calculate number of different
URLs that a user visited in particular
session of their activity on your web
app so if somebody is on your site how
many different URLs do they go to in
their particular session and these
sessions can vary right like some user
only visit to a URLs and their sessions
are two minutes in length or if somebody
sticks around on your YouTube site and
watch is 50 different videos they have a
session which is multiple hours in
length so here the session window is
defined per key so these three windows
windowing concepts allow you to define
like more powerful pipelines and now we
should add a notion of what what happens
in processing time so for processing
time cases beam has a notion of
something called a watermark so let me
describe what a watermark is so a word
running watermark is our best estimate
of till what point in the past have we
collected all the data for so let's say
we were doing running a pipeline right
now and it's about 4 o'clock and we know
that everything that would have happened
from 2 o'clock to 3 o'clock should have
reached our system so that means our
watermark can be a tree it could have
been a head of 3 o'clock but we can't
say the same about the window from 3 to
4 so our watermark is somewhere in the
middle from 3 to 4 so at this point in
time it is safe to calculate the results
for the window which was 2 to 3 but it's
not safe to calculate the results for
window which is 3 to 4 even though it's
been passed for but we know there's
certain data that is still either in
certain buffers or still might be in the
network so now if we go back to our
visualization this is slowly evolving
from a batch pipeline into a streaming
pipeline
we're the green bar here kind of
reflects what our watermark looks like
we're at every point in the time this
was a estimate of where we have seen the
data for and whenever we the watermark
past a certain window we were able to
output the result for that window
because our notion of saying hey we have
seen this data matches but as you know
there's this red dot which is hey there
was a one data point that came much more
after what we thought the watermark had
progressed to so this event that
happened at 9:01 actually showed up like
much much late and we had already
processed Windows ahead of that so next
we are going to talk about how do what
do we do in case of such late data and
how do we refine our result so now we've
talked about what a watermark is and
we're going to talk about the concept
called triggers and firings where let's
say for a particular window we said our
window is 1 R but we wanted to get an
estimate result fired every 10 minutes
so in a sense you can sort of say that
for a particular window you are tagging
the result by either early which is here
I might not have seen all the data for
this window but this is kind of an
estimated value that I expect to be the
output or an on-time firing where when
the watermark cross is a particular
window you are saying this is the result
I would have seen so this was what we
were doing in the previous case and then
a late firing where every time late data
comes in just send me an updated value
and based on these any downstream
consumer can decide what they need to do
where if they want to use the early
results they can choose to use them or
discard them if they see any late data
they can do an update so if the update
is safe and they can mutate the previous
records then they could do that and get
more correct results if it's not they
can choose to discard that and this is
how like being deals with any sort of
late data and guarantees like you're
constantly correcting your results
there are different modes of updating in
beams and for more details there like a
full paper called the data flow model or
if you go to V beam website so this is
what like hey for a particular window we
saw multiple outputs being generated and
not just one as we saw in our previous
use cases so this was like a huge crash
course in the beam what is there's
definitely more information available on
the beam site and if we walk through the
for questions again like customizing the
what where when and how actually helped
us evolve the same model to become a
classic batch pipeline where there was
one window from minus infinity to
infinity to a streaming pipeline that
could handle a data and there are more
examples on the beam website or the
Google Cloud dataflow website so you
should definitely check that out
and I'm going to start talking about the
beam model here and work through some
examples of what the B make API actually
looks like for writing real world
pipelines so X word count is probably
the most popular examples for data
processing I've never seen a framework
not do it so let's do that as Python
developers the first thing I would do is
import a whole bunch of stuff and then
so here being is what we are saying is
we start with a pipeline and the width
Clause here essentially this context is
helping you run the pipeline so when you
exit the context we are going to run the
pipeline for you and a pipe operator
means apply this P transform to my
pipeline right now so in this first line
what we are saying is read some text
data from this input side and read from
text is a built-in transform you can
implement your own transforms as well
and in read from text now our P
collection when this impede this
transform has been applied looks
something like a set where each element
is a line in this text file next
we passed this PHP collection through a
flag map where we split each line into
words so now our P collection after this
transform would look something like
where every element is one word and next
we can run it through a combiner so
combiners here sort of works similar to
how combiners work the Map Reduce where
you can they are essentially doing the
group by key where you're doing the
group by on each of these words and then
counting the number of times this has
been seen so this beam combiner is
actually a combination inside of a group
by key and doing the sum implementation
and it's slightly more efficient because
you can push some of the computation on
the map tasks as well next we format our
output into something that is a string
we want to write to a text file so now
we are getting key value pairs where the
first thing was the word that we saw and
DC was the count and we are just
generating a string which says word :
number of times we saw that and to end
this we are going to write the output
back into a text file which says we are
going to use the right to text transform
and we are going to just write that
output into a directory and you could
use any other file system here such as
s3 or GC s or any remote file system so
if you look at this pipeline here
nowhere have we defined a notion of what
execution framework are we tied to so
this pipeline is actually able to run
either on like kuba Cloud dataflow on
your local machine or or inspire
cufflink so currently python only
supports direct runner and dataflow but
if you were to use the java beam api you
will be able to run the exact same
pipeline on SPARC course link or apex
and next let's so this was the typical
batch pipeline and we're going to slowly
evolve this into a streaming pipeline
so a typical string streaming example I
see is like trending on Twitter so if
you have been on Twitter
on the left side they show what are the
most popular hashtags in some duration
which I don't know what it is and we are
going to kind of create to calculate the
exact same thing
so what we are going to do is we are
going to try to find the most popular
hashtags in the last five minutes at any
given point of time so here is similar
to our previous case we are going to
read from a streaming source this time
so pub/sub is similar to Casca which is
hosted service on google cloud and you
could use Kafka here for what it would
and so we have this Twitter topic that
is constantly sending the streets and we
don't know when this data is going to
end so we try to window our output into
input data into 5-minute windows and
these are sliding windows so our window
moves one minute at a time and the size
of the window is five minutes so at any
given minute we can get the most popular
hashtags in the last five minutes so
next let's say we had a parsing function
so for like the sake of the example I
don't know what the Twitter to it looks
like but we had impaired implemented a
function that went through this JSON
took all the hashtags out and created
elements for each of the hashtags so now
your pea collection is basically a
stream of hashtags each of them are tied
to a particular window they were
assigned to and if you see a single
hashtag would belong to five different
windows here because we have a sliding
window of five minute in size so a
single element is going to go through
five different windows because the
window progress is one minute at a time
next we are going to wrap this combiner
again and the combiner is now actually
going to calculate the sum per window so
we are going to see how many times were
a particular hashtag seen in a sliding
window
so this combiner is going to generate
like the hashtags is going to be counted
in five different windows system and now
we do the same thing as how we would
outputting but this time we try to
output to a database so in this example
I output
to bigquery but you could write to
Cassandra or my sequel or any other
database and so basically the first
thing we are doing is formatting the
output to be readable by whatever the
databases ingestion system reads and
then just writing that out and next like
your service or web app can basically
query this database for like top most
popular things and do calculate hashtags
this way so we saw that the same syntax
we saw for word count which was for a
batch pipeline slowly evolved into a
streaming pipeline where we were doing
like rolling sums on a stream and the
API barely changed actually the only
line we essentially added was windowed
into and now we were doing windowed sums
and so this is now I want to use the
time I have left to talk about what is
the vision for beam and portability so
I've constantly mentioned that you can
run your B pipeline or different
execution engine so now I want to walk
through the architecture for what
enabled beam to actually do this so
currently being Java supports five
different execution runners where which
is Google Cloud dataflow apache spark
apache flink such apex and gear pump I
think air pump still incubating so to
die amburn into this so first thing we
see and what the user interacts with is
a pipeline SDK so you can see an SDK in
your particular frame like favorite
language where there is a Java SDK there
is a Python SDK and you could assume
that the nod SDK or other languages in
the future and the user is going to use
the same primitives we saw per click
windowing or flat map or map to write
their pipeline graph so now once they
have expesive ide what their dag looks
like we are going to convert this graph
into a language agnostic standard format
so here the two things to note you would
still have closures that are serialized
and that can only be uncivilized in your
particular language so if you were using
the Python function we would pickle the
function and only unpick only Python
would be able to unpick alert but this
graph is basically defining what the
word DP transformer nodes are actually
made of so this be there are primitive
nodes that the graph understands so hey
this is a pardhu this is a map this is a
group by key and your graph is defined
using those and every node is tied to a
UUID or u RN which is a cross
inconsistent across different languages
so now that you have formed this
language agnostic representation of your
pipeline graph you still need something
to understand what your primitives look
how your parameters were execute in that
particular language so corresponding to
each SDK there is an execution harness
that is tied to it
so for let's say python this execution
harness is the one that's going to like
be pickle your code and run it across
all elements so the execution harness
provides the consistent environment for
executing your code so if you had a
Python 3.6 SDK it would be tied to a
Python 3.6 HD running harness and you
might be able to augment that with by
installing other libraries that you are
using but now no matter what runner you
were using because this is a docker
based environment this is consistent
across wherever you take it so if you
were running in your local machine
you're still getting the same execution
harness which your remote execution
framework might use so if SPARC spins up
a worker if they spin up the exact same
execution harness they get the
consistent environment so you're not
having a mismatch between how your
pipeline ran on one framework versus the
other one and you're not tuning your
environment constantly but as we see
these execution harnesses in different
languages right like you had a Java
harness you had a Python harness we
still need a consistent API for all of
these to talk to what the execution
framework looks like so this is where
funny API comes in where this is a
consistent API that is exposed by all of
these docker
dinner's and this is how they send or
receive data or report matrix report
errors anything that might happen and so
now we have basically with this diagram
right we have consistent created a
consistent representation of what the
users graph looked like and a consistent
API which each of the workers speak and
you can kind of assume where I am going
with this where now you have different
runners so the runners basically sit in
the middle where the understand the
common representation of each runner epi
graph they also understand how to talk
to different workers using different API
and then each execution framework is
still responsible for managing resources
across across different machines or
coordinating work between different
workers but no part of the runner or
what language the runner supports is
integrated with what language the user
can write their pipeline in so like
because they're talking over a
particular API protocol SPARC can talk
to different like Haskell for harness
using different API and it doesn't
matter if the execution worker is
learning is running Haskell or Python or
R because and SPARC is written in Scala
that then goes toward like now separate
concepts and this is how we try to like
this is what beam envisions and to be
the future so that you can take your
pipeline and run it wherever you want
you shouldn't be able to happen to be
implement your pipeline constantly based
on like hey this is my language or this
is what rather I am committed to today
and so there are different parts which
you can help out on beam is an open
source project
it's a top-level Apache project now and
you can either help with writing
different SDKs you can help define the
runner API and for api graphs you can
help with writing new execution systems
or adding more runners which support
these protocols
so to learn more about beam you can
check the beam website all the code is
available on github currently we have
two SDKs all the issues are dragged on
JIRA and there are two mailing lists
which are definitely worth checking out
one is the user mailing list where if
you are using beam and you want to give
feedback about what you like what you
found hard what you found
easy how can we improve what sort of new
connector should we add definitely help
us give that feedback there or there is
a developer mailing list so if you want
to help out and if you're just starting
out and don't know where to begin that
might be a good place to start where we
can help you find the right JIRA issue
for you to tackle and should be pair up
with someone who might be able to guide
yourself so at this point thank you for
taking the time to listen to me and I
can you can find me online I can answer
name Thank You surak's if anybody has
questions they can tweet them here at
that PI data Seattle so you gave us a
couple of simple examples using beam
have you implemented anything more
complicated in a beam diagram already
yes so basically so beam is the primary
SDK which is used by like Google Cloud
dataflow and there are a lot of users
who'd like run jobs which do a petabyte
shuffles and complicated Steven jobs and
if you look at if you go on the beam
website there is the mobile gaming
example is actually implemented where we
go through a stream and update data for
like if you see late data what happens
and all the things we talked about and
all these concepts are actually
implemented as one example where you see
the pipeline of walls so there might be
a good place to check out thank you
questions in the room
thank taking Twitter real quick here
yeah so basically in being the kind of
override the or character to say hey
this is a P transform that what I want
to pipe my output through or like pipe
my input through this yeah so it's not
the fights in specific thing it's a beam
thing yeah yeah
yes so basically you can kind of
implement either any one of those with
beam where essentially lambda or copper
required you to run a batch pipeline as
well as a streaming pipeline but what we
hope is with the implementation of how
we handle a data you can kind of achieve
the exact same results with without
running the batch pipeline in parallel
with the streaming pipeline because the
reason we did that you do lambda
architecture is because you're not sure
that your stream had processed all the
data or not and you want you're kind of
like fixing the result post hoc with a
batch pipeline so if you had a good way
to handle a data I think you would be
able to achieve the same result with the
exact streaming pipeline itself and this
is what we are kind of hoping to do but
you could definitely write your bad job
and streaming job using beam as well
you mentioned that there are some folks
using this already yeah what kind of
adoption are you see who use a couple of
specific adoption examples yeah so one
example is fortify basically maintains a
scholar STK they haven't given it back
there's an open issue about like giving
it back to the beam community but all of
Spotify pipelines are sort of written in
beam is an example and squirt if I'd
there's a lot of string processing
because of like the music player and
continuous data coming in the given
community has had like 200 odd computers
who work in like different organizations
and you start flink is actually like
fling or data like several people from
the Apache fling PMC also our computers
and beam and help out with like driving
beam adoption for like this link
execution system yeah I just as a
reminder we're getting near the end of
our time session if you want to make it
to your next session it's about five
minutes until the start of the next one
so what is your favorite implementation
in beam right now what what project was
the most fun for you or the the most
interesting to implement beam actually
for me it was I think seeing the fun API
and the runner API vision evolve and
defining those to be a language agnostic
system where you it was much more easier
to add new languages there without
having being tied to with the execution
framework supports it or not and that
was definitely super fun to implement
did you make sure that Spotify is added
got a Scala SDK for this do you know of
any other SDKs currently in development
yes so there are open JIRA issues about
writing a go SDK and we also there is a
branch developing a sequel SDK so those
two are definitely in progress and these
45 n is open source on their account on
github and then beam internally has
checked in versions for Java and Python
and if you want to write a new SDK you
definitely
come to and really definitely support
about that yes yes so it's already
implemented in its in DB master and
really it is released with every beam
version yeah that's a good question we
are actually at Microsoft of course so
is there any net language currently
listed for the SDK uh no but you're
welcome to start the G ratio and hiding
a branch to help contribute on that
[Music]
thank you very much Sarah